ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono pa vj per oggi stiamo sul
siamo cioè più di 91 fottutissimi
episodi ancora non riesco a dire la
intro decentemente fantastico ragazzi la
prima cosa che voglio fare è il tipo
fifa quindi si fa qui in dio santo
almeno leggere italiano di fa 16 qui
sala io io non ho mai toccato fifa in
vita mia quindi facciamo un quiz su fifa
giusto per capire quanto riesco a far
pagare è il giocatore più votato in
ultimate team
credo che se la giochino cristiano
ronaldo e messi io credo credo sia credo
sia macchinoso macchine a questo era
facile chi è il giocatore con più forza
e andrei o sub baros sapete che gli
altri non sono anche chi cazzo sono mi
andrei su l'unico che conosco di apple
ma prendiamo iddio per pronunciare con
il nome degli avercela la forza
procurate i jedi minchia impossibile
l'ho preso quelli di questi giocatori
non è stato incluso nel team slayer
neymar thiago silva a luka modric e luis
suarez non ho la più pallida vero
speriamo suarez perché se morde magari a
casa sua e meglio
eccolo di merda tanto ragazzi mi è
rimasto una eco questa il dente di
suarez che ho appena un perfetto
wizzair cosa devi fare come prossimo qui
si guarda fi deadpool per l'amor di dio
perché giorno di calcio proprio meno che
zero fra concert ad ora ma d'or amateur
ore per man
ok sto laureando in medicina aiutami a a
curare show reca cliccando sul col mouse
sul sull'attrezzo corretto va bene e sto
e graduale e stava graduando una
camomilla prima che credo fa caccia vita
prima suo tech poi prendiamo con la mano
ad ospitare ok perfetto è la madonna che
caccia in settima piazza con questo
sparisci
perché un insetto dovrebbe mai fare
questo verso non pensavo che gli insetti
suonassero come dei bambini però si sta
sempre di più da una vita fantastica
questo gioco istruttivo cazzo non ci
fosse più in funzione gli togliamo
perfetto grazie le pinze io non so che
cosa sto facendo lega pro sto facendo
del mio dio non svitando io devo svitare
cosa ancora non ho capito perché prove
porca eva sono curioso di sentire che
verso fa lui mica il dubbio esistenziale
il verso dei ragni non ho mai saputo a
porca [ __ ] ma che schifo
la cosa strana è che suona più o meno
come me da bambino quando mangiavo gli
asparagi più o meno la stessa cosa per
la ragazza aveva scoperto che i ragni
ruttano in realtà sta cosa non lo sapevo
neanche ce l'abbiamo faccio messo una
vita e mezza però ce l'ho fatta
per l'amor di dio che percio abbiamo
fatto perché fa il verso dei ragni non
sarai mica un ragno vas ha convinto poi
fotte serie trovi orchi ho finalmente
uno dei uno decente maledizione un troll
di duke che potevano farlo un po prima
lo aspettavo da una vita e non centrare
il buco fantastico sono capaci a
centrali di me la cavo a.cam ignota ho
letto fatto boccia le gambe ragazzi ma
ce l'ho fatta
ok stanno non mi alzavo chang regate su
c'è pure le gambe ce la facciamo ragazzi
a fare un livello proprio divo di quelli
della avventura tipo questo jungle
adventure un livello di bello un livello
di avventura suisse non lo faccio da una
vita e mezza cioè mio dio fatemelo
vedere un cazzo di livello decente o un
touch the water non devo toccare l'acqua
va bene perché sono non sono gesù che ci
cammina sopra
no non sono gesù è il game over
quell'uomo che non poteva toccare
l'acqua e cazzo devi solo pezzi i pgt a
vecchi sopravvive via delle cadute
pazzesche esplosioni poi entrava in
acqua e morivi fantastico e ciao zio
come sai sono banane quelle note le
metti nel culo frate nome nei lanci
grazie a chi ha crediti alimenti di cui
ha sentito è
e non è che posso passare da schivare le
cose che milan ci sei bello il suo lab
al timing cioè tutto riguardo a
tempistiche e io ne ho di tempistica mi
chiamerò da vendere sapete che non ce la
farò mai nella mia vita a fare studi
vennero ve lo dico che culo che
purissimo ma non è vero ma non ne vada
non l'avevano ancora visto con la merda
piano zio piano che quella roba punge di
più di tua madre quando porti un 2 a
casa il piano bravo sapete quanto odio
gli anziani ci mancava solo che mi
dessero il tempismo benvenuto
nell'albero del mistero che cazzo è
peter pan trichechi dell'ever su get up
warsak fatto perché c'è una ragnatela mi
deve spaventare ci sono i ragni che
praticamente è un gioco per deficienti
insomma grazie ho capito che faccio
pagare che non sono anche i calciatori
basilari che non conosco un cazzo però
mio dio almeno in questo non prendetemi
per il culo già mio dio credo ragazzi
che sia la prova finale jump ce l'ho
fatta non ci posso creare non ancora
finito ok perfetto già fatta cosa vuoi
sono incastrati simo z end ok a devo
prendere una cosa fantastica
la madonna marco barzanti swing medio
facciamo rock swing decente una volta
nella vita
io dicevo sul serio zio cioè non è che
adesso mipi per il culo che intendevo
facciamo rock swing serio facciamo rock
swing serio
facciamo un rock kings serio zio c'è un
pertugio ok c'è un pertugio quando sei
uscito la tua madre il parcheggio era
più grosso di quello dai zio maledizione
a me soldi fama e belle donne minchia
ragazzi la tattica di rimorchio del 2016
ho finito un rock swing suo ep wings
esci con me pupa o no ecco bello questo
proprio il tipo di livello visto periodo
mi piace al coraggio bellissimo guarda
disquisito se yourself fanno serio self
oddio questi livelli qui minchia conto
vi ammazzerei frate prendi tornar
deretano per favore grazie ciao
e stato bello
magari oggi ostile riceve lo dica
processo jet ski challenge fava questo o
più o meno presse spacebar quello
sarebbe un jetpack zio sembra tipo che
il caso dei fatto dai bambini problemi
per l'amor di dio non so pensare quando
mi darà la patente lega che tragedia non
riesco mai a guidare un jetpack più
fatto dai bambini fantastico non ho
parcheggiato ho parcheggiato news da
landmine mica inizialmente avoletto usa
al lavandino una roba del genere rosa
non ci credo mai
porca eva così fatta la ghenga il primo
tentativo assoluto e concia farò mai più
beh guarda sei andato più a sinistra di
quel poco ha vinto il consenso o io o li
ha tirati su uomo allora vuoi proprio
deludermi hai deciso così ma vaffan
cuore minchia di deficienti mica devi
solo tir dai zio devi fare una roba devi
fare solo per i soci dati su dio non è
difficile o frate se non riesci
veramente adesso datti all'ippica o fai
qualcosa al muro di cui l'uomo donna poi
ditemi perché non conosco un cazzo di
calcio non ci riesco a passare ma anche
in mezzo alle palle sempre in mezzo alle
palle sempre in mezzo dai zio michè
almeno 45 minuti
complimenti frate un record che stai
chiedendo se possa sopravvivere
oddio cos'è sta roba come faccio a
sabato ce l'ho fatta subito c'è più o
meno tra i tuchini rosse pro a ucciderti
ma questo bravissimo credit dai zio ma
sei sempre
ma come come facciano come fai a non
morire ma cosa ma se minchia se provo
sollievo
ok grazie grazie a dio un livello che si
chiama el 3 fatto da guardian 666 deve
essere meraviglioso bellissimo che bello
valle questi sono scarafaggio sono ragni
quali dei due
ciao zio come sai perché i miei tagliato
il pene ragazzi abbiamo appena scoperto
che all'inferno non si può entrare col
bene ciao nonno come stai
oddio solo cascando di brutto sono gravi
salve ciao nonno come sai perfetto e
senti zio potresti evitare di lanciarmi
cose addosso tipo cateni che cazzo è
roba lì vabbè è matteo scalve ma guarda
che se sei tu non ti riconosco è da
prima e devo passare posso grazie motivi
di sì perché siamo tutti con uno c'è chi
sta livello scusate un attimo jason cui
stai
e va beh devo prendere questo è lo
trascinati perché morì veloce velo non
ci credo mai sono morto però un
millimetro e mezzo ma veramente
lei subito questa ragazzina era da fini
era era veramente la fine mi è venuto un
dubbio ragazzi ma se cerco tipo tipo fa
vj adventures non ci stava bene
angelo al cielo dell'avventura miapa vj
adventure 1 non l'ho mai fatte queste
credo che figata
un giorno a me questa tela racconta
proprio un giorno fuori fa vj ragazzo
ridi in anno di merda io devo andare
avanti un gioco ci ha scritto un giorno
puntini puntini e non continua c'è nel
senso un giorno e finisce di ok la tua
morte vicina set
non credevo così tanto vicina mio dio va
beh a parte la mia morte vicina no vabbè
questa è la fine degli haters insomma in
poche parole questo è questa
i miei amici si vendicheranno mi stai
guardando sia cioè che cazzo che vendica
che non c'è manco più il culo ai ragazzi
con quello che l'episodio è stato strano
velo smetterla di pronunciare sentenze
alla fine di di è più mi chiameranno
senso ma neanche lontanamente le cose
che dico stiamo arrivando al centesimo e
una volta che arriveremo al centesimo
non avete idea come al solito seguito è
piaciuto il suo commento è un mi piace
anche la voce di facebook e come nei
video stata descrizione senza vestiti
schede ci vediamo al prossimo vinto dai
ragazzi